in a battle for his political life Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau absorbed
withering attacks from both sides Justin
Trudeau only pretends to stand up for
Canada you know he's very good at
pretending things he can't even remember
how many times he put black face on in
the only english-language debate in
Canada's brief 40 day campaign again and
again Trudeau took fire first from the
right mr. Trudeau you are a phony and
you are a fraud and you do not deserve
to govern this country and then from the
left the problem is is that you set a
lot of these things in 2015 so what's it
gonna take now for Canadians to believe
that you're actually gonna fall through
your promises what's it gonna take for
you to follow through on these
commitments because your words are not a
good enough thing it's not good enough
to have better rhetoric than Mr Shearer
you bought a pipeline it can't be a
climate leader and spend 10 to 13
billion dollars more on a project that
by itself blows through our carbon
budget it was reminiscent of Trudeau's
charismatic debut on the political scene
in a celebrity boxing match as in that
fight he struck back first to the
People's Party candidate who was accused
of tweeting bigotry to say publicly what
Mr Shearer thinks privately and then
directly to his closest rival
Conservative Party leader Andrew Shearer
who arrived to mock and chants of USA
that is a reference to his recently
revealed dual Canadian and US
citizenship and your plan is to rip up
the only serious plan to fight climate
change
Canada has ever had Canadian Tire
Shearer has vowed to eliminate Trudeau's
carbon tax which he calls too expensive
polls give only Trudeau and Shearer a
realistic chance of winning a mandate in
the October 21st election but the other
candidates could become king makers
analysts expect the Liberal Party to
lose seats possibly even its majority
and that would leave each side
scrambling to form a coalition with
enough votes to control Parliament and
the prime ministership in the end
political analysts say the campaign is a
referendum on Trudeau's tenure
the question is do we want to continue
for the 4th for next year's with Trudeau
or is it that bad that we want to change
and go back to the previous government
at a time we arc with a contentious
field vying for position just two weeks
from Election Day none of the contenders
seem to want to leave a cross word
unspoken John Hendren al-jazeera
Gatineau Quebec